joining us now one of our favorite
guests and i i don't just say that for
everyone he can attest to it vikings
receiver stefan dig staphon welcome back
how are you buddy i'm awesome thanks for
having me i appreciate you guys no
problem
so uh i was hoping last year when we
when we saw you in minneapolis that this
year we wouldn't be able to talk to your
super bowl yeah because you'd be getting
ready to play in the game maybe maybe
next year yeah yeah i've been saying
maybe next year for the vikings for 40
years it's okay it's okay it's coming
you got to have some patience i have i
have faith he's in love with you okay
and the vikings i mean he cries when you
guys don't play well but this is what i
want you to do first thing is he already
wants to trade kirk cousins he wants him
off the team already so so much for me
asking questions
all right all right listen let me talk
about it yeah um i'm gonna give you
i'm gonna give you all the good you need
first year yep you know
new system new quarterback new receivers
everybody's new still gotta you know
still gotta adjust
and you know uh there's a lot of room
for improvement you know we've had a lot
of sparks we had some good games some
things that you saw that we could be
could be really special um and doing it
on a consistent basis is something
that's going to come with time and you
can look forward to time it's not
working against us it's working with us
okay i took all of what you said and put
it in my brain i'm a bears fan so i'm
going to say this
what about
the most awkward pre-game speech of all
time on that sunday night football when
he's like they flex the game because of
us not because of the bears
i still think that's kind of true no
it's not no i don't think that's true
i'm lying i'm not a i'm not a bear i
don't i don't hate the bears you know we
play the bears twice a year but you know
uh
we're electrifying like we really are
pretty good all right
you guys you guys just got a good
defense this past season this is right
hard last year i know you i know you
were a fan with jay cutler who was there
oh i love you i actually though the joke
is i'm i still think jay cutler is a
fantastic he's the best quarterback ever
yes right right all bears fans correct
you know after what happened last year
with the big catch and the advance to
the nfc championship and then kirk comes
in and i just feel like the expectations
were too high and there was never really
an effort to make it realistic because
the schedule was so much tougher last
year and big games in prime time and
everybody's giving you the best did you
sense last year the teams were giving
you guys like a a tougher game than the
prior year uh not really just cause like
you know whatever that question
every game is that way every game is
that way everybody gonna get your best
shot and you know people definitely have
something to prove each and every game
but for us you know we did have a tough
schedule but you got to play everybody
you know very few teams have to play
everybody you know but we had to go see
pretty much everybody and uh we had to
perform well but as far as the
expectations being too high our
expectations were high you know we
everybody wanted to play well we wanted
it to all go good and have ice cream and
cake at the end of the year but that's
just not how it shakes out you know you
got to put a lot of work in just to be
pretty good and you can't beat yourself
do you see any big changes this year is
it just continue with what you're saying
first year with kirk cousins second year
will be better or do you think something
dramatic needs to happen i think it's
going to we're going with the same
mentality we've already had a couple of
coaching changes um from my
understanding so yeah it's going to be
it's going to be some moving parts but
i've had a lot of moving parts since i
got in the league i've had a different
quarterback almost every year i've had a
a different coach you know so i'm kind
of used to change at this point i just
uh when it's time i just roll with the
punches so you don't want a different
quarterback for next year no no he does
not they had i'm just making sure that's
the coordinator issues they had injuries
on the o-line stop blaming damn
and listen to the passing of tony
sparano right before the story
that was devastating to the team that
was tough to come back from how about uh
i mean you're the dynamic duo of you and
adam thielen just like talk about what
he brings to the table yeah i mean do
you guys compete throughout the week do
you look at the game and on the stat
board and go oh no no no it's you know
for me i've always been a team guy yeah
so as far as like uh the stats and that
kind of thing how they come up is how
they come up you can't really control it
especially uh when you got two good
receivers you know and i um during the
week we push each other real real hard
in practice we want to go we want to be
perfect in practice because it'll make
the game real easy because the guys you
go against every every day you know for
what 17 weeks they know you they know
what you're going to do they've seen the
same moves over and over so winning and
practice is going to be huge and then it
carries over to the game you know i love
montgomery yeah i mean do you what do
you feel like he gets discredited a
little bit like he doesn't get named as
far as you know in the upper class of
receivers
it's i would say it's crazy because you
know what with adam like he's p they
treat him like like this little like uh
not making a lot of noise not flashy
right but more so like i would say like
a wide receiver you know like they
appreciate the appreciation of them i
have yeah and he's a guy that's worked
hard to get where he is you know he he
gives you that wes welker or that you
know but better you know he can play any
position he has great hands he can run
any route and he has sneaky speed yeah
we make fun of him for being slow but he
can do pretty much everything and people
don't give him enough credit it's like
one of those things that you're just
gonna have to break through yeah you
know
i know you're a big starbucks guy and
starbucks has a new product new product
that you have with you there tell us
about tivana uh i'm excited to partner
with them you know i love starbucks
anybody who know me like as my close
friends go to everyday type of things so
uh it's definitely something i'm blessed
with i was i blessed the opportunity as
well to go to seattle when we played
seattle um to the headquarters you know
uh we got i got to see the t developers
and how what goes into making tea and
that kind of thing so i had a great time
kind of made my own digs delight you
know that's the only pr that's a
personal thing that i got so uh it was
an exciting thing to do and uh i'm
looking forward to working with them you
know you need to grab a mango where's
your starbucks chain hey hey you know me
oh where is it is it on don't think you
know me i'm drinking starbucks
it's actually in my room i i'll let you
borrow it did you put it in the safe
you always got to put your stuff in the
safe when you're staying in the hotel
yeah i'm i'm i let people you know do
bad things by themselves yeah yeah yeah
nice good to know where are you
hey listen i'm the de facto commissioner
of big ten football and i have yet to
allow maryland into the conference wow
so i'm gonna give you a chance to plead
your case
um
we gave ohio state a good run yeah there
you go that's uh you're out right that's
it
you're
so much the maryland flag i never got
it's because of where we're from you
know i know but like the actual flag
four flags you're uniform flags in one
yeah your uniforms are horrible
they're horrible
they're not haters i used to swag them
though yeah
all right you guys are close you guys
are close we're gonna do fishbowl wait
but as you're like who's the db that you
hate seeing like who's the guy that
you're just i know you don't fear
anybody and you're the man but who's the
guy that's like in your first few years
where you've just been like damn he's
annoying
it's a couple guys i really thought it
was fun my first year going against
richard sherman and then like this this
past year going against mr sherman you
know uh it's more because i'm older now
yeah and then when i was younger it's
like they were good that defense was
good yeah they were a damn good defense
right you know we didn't have a lot of
time to get the ball off like it was
when nor was here so we did a lot of
quick stuff and i was like it's damn
like they they they pretty much
seattle yeah yeah okay go ahead fish
bullet when was the last time you cried
hmm
when was the last time you cried bears
week seven week 17 yeah
that was the last time i cried i cry
every time last time i cried
i probably cried like a couple weeks ago
but they were like
cold tears because it was so cold out oh
okay you know you start yeah yeah yeah
yeah hit you right in your eyes it just
hits your lungs
your nostrils it's like negative 50
there yeah yeah yeah you get out of
there when the season's over right here
i am yeah that's right
i'm a crier like i cry at the end of
field of dreams like i'm a dork like
that i don't even know what to say
you're one hell of a door armageddon
i'll cry in the shower we are armageddon
we're out of time we're out of time
stefan great scene as always we'll check
out tivonne i'm going to drink that so
again i hope you have another one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports